después de neymar mbappe y más
recientemente sergio ramos leo messi se
une a las filas del parís saint germain
atrás quedaron las lágrimas tras partir
del barcelona en su primera conferencia
de prensa como miembro del equipo
confesó su alegría de estar en la
capital francesa y reiteró su ambición
de más títulos bueno con muchísima
ilusión como ghana que que nunca
muchas veces lo dije 'me mi objetivo y
mi sueño de poder volver a levantar otra
champions messi estuvo acompañado por
nacer al khelaifi presidente del club
quien respondió así cuando le
preguntaron por el fair play financiero
la norma que regula los gastos de los
equipos europeos
seguimos la normativa del fair play
financiero desde el primer día que
empezamos y hasta el final siempre
cumpliremos esta normativa antes de
hacer cualquier cosa básicamente miramos
con nuestros consejeros financieros
comerciales y legales
y mientras tanto en las calles desde muy
temprano la fila para ingresar a la
tienda oficial del club se perdía de
vista los aficionados no esperaron para
disputarse las nuevas camisetas con el
nombre del astro argentino la máscara de
165 euros
casi dos horas es mucho tiempo pero
estamos contentos ya lo logramos al fin
podemos tener nuestra recompensa
mes y no puso fecha para su debut con
los colores del psg según el astro
argentino tiene que realizar una
pretemporada propia para ponerse a punto
después de un mes de vacaciones tras
haber ganado la copa américa con su
selección
[Música]